president vladimir zelinsky tells al
jazeera he regrets ukraine gave up its
nuclear weapons in the 1990s and he
named several governments that could
give security guarantees to protect his
country one of them is china another is
russia but will anyone actually do that
this is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm rob
matheson ukraine is preparing for what
it says will be fierce fighting with
russian forces president vladimir
zelinski's told al jazeera that russia
could renew its attack on kiev if
ukrainian forces fail on the eastern
front mass evacuations have been carried
out in the eastern city of kramatowsk on
friday more than 50 people were killed
in a strike on a railway station ukraine
says russia fired missiles while
thousands of civilians were waiting to
catch trains russia says it's not to
blame it says kiev is responsible
ukrainian forces have managed to retake
other times and zelensky says that's
giving people new hope
we can see that the war is not over yet
but so many people are excited and happy
that some areas have been liberated and
i'm pleased to speak about such places
because in others people are dying
some because of the blockades and others
because they're being killed by russian
soldiers
but we have put up a fierce response and
they've failed to take keeve
president zelinski also says that if
ukraine was to be a neutral or
non-aligned country it would need
security guarantees from foreign
governments and russia would have to be
part of that
i think that this agreement would be
impossible without russian federation so
that's
that's another story really
then
i know that ireland
wanted and some other countries wanted
to consider becoming security guarantees
we will also ask for china france and
germany they also are aware of
this situation and so far they are
showing some sort of respect and support
but
in addition to support and assistance we
need to have very detailed negotiations
in order to understand
which country is ready to provide
provide which specific support and
assistance and guarantees
ganzalensky suggests ukraine became weak
and at greater risk from invasion when
it gave away its nuclear capabilities
without first securing stronger
guarantees than those in the budapest
memorandum of 1994.
how could you give up the weapons in
such a way
without signing any serious document
just
making a big present for what
who
have received that i mean what have
received
what we have received what ukraine has
received we have received a war and this
is one of the reasons we have become
weaker we have weakened our status our
defense
we have weakened our population
this is what we have given away we have
given away the life
of those people who died this is one of
the reasons
once again i would like to reiterate
it's not
uh because you would you would be
willing to use that absolutely not
okay let's bring in our guests peter
zamayev is executive director of eurasia
democracy initiative he's joining us on
skype from near keeve i'm from brussels
david o'sullivan is a former secretary
general of the european commission he's
currently director general of the
institute of international and european
affairs and from glasgow in the uk anton
babashin is the editorial director at
riddle russia it's an online journal on
russian affairs gentlemen thank you very
much indeed for being with us i want to
talk about this uh reference that the
president of ukraine has made with
regard to nuclear weapons peter let me
start with you if ukraine still had
nuclear weapons after the 1990s what
could we have been seeing in ukraine now
well uh you know that that remark
actually he
first made during the munich security
conference a few days before the
invasion i was there in the room uh when
he said it and the russians actually
then later used this as an excuse you
know as one of the you know their you
know reasons to start the war that look
ukraine is gung-ho about going nuclear
and they're gonna nuke us but you know
unfortunately uh you know uh russians
would have used any pretext you know uh
to do so they don't need a pretext
obviously uh i when i was getting my
master's degree at columbia university
one was one of my professors was kenneth
waltz a very well-known theoretician of
the so-called theory of nuclear peace
according to which nuclear weapons uh
are you know probably the closest uh
countries have to a security clad
guarantee of their you know security on
you know needless to say uh you know
when you're dealing with a country like
russia uh
it does appear that ukraine would have
been probably better off if it had kept
its nuclear weapons and that's why we
have this uh situation this is where we
are right now and we're trying to find a
formula which would be the next best
thing to uh you know nato membership for
ukraine but that will be the topic of
our you know discussion today uh david
sullivan if i understand it correctly
many of the nuclear weapons we were
talking about in the 1990s were actually
soviet weapons and the ukrainians had
access to them but the russians at least
in the early days had the codes for them
do you think that ukraine was wise to
give up that nuclear power and did it
actually have much of a nuclear power to
begin with
well i think that's a very good point
rob i i indeed they were soviet weapons
they were based in ukraine and ukraine
had physical access to them but i also
understand that there were some limits
to their ability actually to to use them
or to to to uh
to fire them
i also understand that meant a lot of
the equipment was already somewhat
degraded and not in not in very good
shape so my personal view i mean i
perfectly understand why ukraine feels
extremely cheated particularly from the
guarantees that were given
of their territorial sovereignty in
return for uh letting the weapons go
back to to to to russia but honestly i i
i don't think it was it was viable for a
relatively small country in the middle
of europe uh to be nuclear-armed i think
it would have caused more problems for
ukraine uh rather than solving any and i
think it could have been quite
destabilizing in the region so i think
that ukraine made the right decision at
the time but they are absolutely right
to point out uh that the guarantees they
got in in return for doing that have not
been respected by russia and this of
course is a flagrant breach of the
undertakings which were given which
started with the nxa of crimea
i want to come on to the security
guarantees in a moment but anton
barbershine do you think given what our
two previous speakers have said that it
would have made any difference at all if
ukraine had had access to uh some sort
of nuclear power some sort of nuclear
force um would it have made any
difference to russia
well i have to say that i agree fully
with what was already
uh said i mean at the time in the early
90s it absolutely made sense for you
praying to give it up and of course it
would have made uh the situation
completely different if in 2014 ukraine
had them but
at the moment we're only seeing that the
talk of nuclear ukraine is being used
instrumentalized by russian propaganda
to kind of beef up uh the
the efforts
to de-uh militarize the great
okay let's talk about the security
guarantees that um the president has
been talking about the the in the clip
that we heard earlier on he was saying
he gave a list of countries that could
be security guarantors i want to ask
first of all um anton i'm going to stay
with you
what is your understanding of what is
involved in being a security guarantor
under circumstances like this
well that's an extremely interesting
question and i do not quite
understand what sort of security
guarantees mean in a moment i mean uh
when the the talk of it initially came
up it was i think phrases something
close to the article 5 of nato
which sounds quite bizarre because
russian side actually did not comment
all that much on that because they knew
quite well that this is something
european nations would not be able to
provide to ukraine so this is all
rhetoric i mean it's nothing no one
could guarantee ukraine to intervene
to give it more than it's already giving
at the moment or to give something that
is uh ukraine was denied for instance de
facto membership of nato so i don't
really think that at this point we're
quite there
yet to be discussing who could be the
security guarantees because the war is
still enveloping we are probably going
to see um heavy fighting next week and
pretty much throughout april
at least moscow is still
focused on achieving a decisive military
victory on the ground
so all the talk about potential security
guarantees
well is a bit premature peter what's
your assessment of the this talk of
security guarantees is is this just
rhetoric there is could it actually lead
to to something the basis of some sort
of discussion at the very least
well i absolutely agree with the
previous speaker you know this is uh not
a very terrible topic um on the eve of
uh
uh decisive battle what is promising to
be a decisive battle you know
with uh with the uh with tank armies and
artillery this is what the ukrainian
side is saying we should be expecting
and ukraine is getting uh heavy weaponry
as well not only defensive but offensive
um you know so we are looking we're
staring at a very very difficult uh
scenario in the next two weeks and keep
in mind that may 9th is a sacred
you know day in
italy over the nazi germany vladimir
putin is going to have to pony up some
victories to show his subjects uh during
the military parade so uh it's all going
to be obviously decided uh on the
battlefield not diplomatically uh after
that and vladimir zelanski has said this
you know he does believe that only by
meeting vladimir putin personally uh we
could hope for some kind of a you know a
breakthrough diplomatic breakthrough but
only after ukraine wins the battle i
mean it's contrary to what we you know
grow up hearing from diplomats you know
there's no military solution to this or
that conflict unfortunately we are at a
point where only a military uh solution
is feasible and only after decisive
showing by ukraine's military and let me
just add a few points you know the
several issues remain
very authority and without them we
cannot hope for any sort of discussion
of a security guarantee unless russia
commits to paying ukraine reparations
hundreds of billions of dollars of
damage has been inflicted on ukraine's
infrastructure needless to say countless
lives we don't know the exact figure but
it may be thousands and thousands and
thousands then the very difficult
question of territorial concessions i
mean are we talking about pre-february
24th withdrawal of troops right uh or
pre-2014 obviously without the
withdrawal of troops at least
to the positions before the 24th of
february we cannot talk about any
significant you know breakthrough and
finally finally kiev has said that there
will be no diplomatic uh agreement no
peace on you know if it involves
whitewashing russian war crimes during
the invasion obviously butcher
david i want to ask you because they
just sort of to talk about this uh this
idea of security guarantee because it's
interesting why the president should
feel it's appropriate to bring it up
given the points that the gentleman have
all have already made and also one would
imagine that if like the list he gave of
possible guarantors included the us the
uk and russia if those guarantors were
in place then surely if there was any
incident at all in ukraine it could
bring those guarantors directly into
conflict with each other and one would
imagine foreign governor governments do
not want to do that which is actually
what we're seeing at the moment with
nato
yes i i i think i understand what
president zalinski was trying to do he
was trying to on the one hand concede
that ukraine would not join nato which
is you know sort of slightly false but
nonetheless
it is the line that moscow is peddling
and he was but at the same time he was
trying to give his country a secure
future by saying well i'm not going to
join we're not going to join nato but we
want the rest of you collectively to
agree to underwrite our security and he
wants the permanent members of the u.n
security council uh he wants a range of
other countries now i agree entirely
with two previous speakers antonin and
peter that uh frankly this is you know
this is not the subject of the moment uh
and will only come back if and when the
military situation has created a
situation where where diplomacy becomes
relevant again but i do see what the
president was was trying to do i'm i'm
skeptical as to whether it's achievable
we we've had in the past there were
guarantors for cyprus uh the uk greece
and turkey and then turkey was one of
the guarantors that invaded northern
cyprus and and
neither of the other two could do
anything about it so uh you know the
history of these things is is not is not
particularly happy so i understand the
idea i i get what the president was was
trying to put put in into play but there
are many many obstacles to to making
such a move successful and and the
difference i think is that he wants a a
really binding international treaty very
different in nature to the budapest
memorandum which which was the
guarantees on territorial uh sovereignty
given after the uh exchange of the
nuclear weapons so i think he's looking
for a much more
legally binding instrument and as you
say i think any country will be very
wary to sign up to that if it means that
they might have to commit troops uh in
the event of an incident
you've all referred to uh the the coming
uh conflict that we're gonna see in
ukraine that uh the president himself
has referred to uh particularly in the
east anton let me ask you
so far we have seen russia move towards
kiev but stop we've seen it move towards
mario paul and destroy much of of mario
paul there seems to be a suggestion it
is if not pulling back then refocusing
towards the east of the country
what's your assessment of why
russia is doing that what putin is
trying to achieve by making that initial
move and then moving back
well i think the answer is quite obvious
it was the initial miscalculation of how
easy it would be for russian troops to
march through ukraine and in fact it
turned out to be quite
messy and quite bloody and russian
troops were not able to acquire uh the
goals that they had and plan and store
for them so
they are just counting on the fact that
they still could amass
a significant enough group of forces in
the east of ukraine uh to essentially
crush uh ukrainian military resistance
to claim a certain amount of territory
and probably to incorporate that either
in dpr dlnr
or directly into the russian state and
claim this to be some sort of
intermediary uh scenario for for the day
but this regrouping essentially is
happening there because they were not
able to accomplish
what was initially planned because
russia is taking heavy losses and
ukraine is fighting quite fiercely so
this is uh this is not as straight a ga
and probably not even strategy
it's probably plan c if mike can uh
you know look into that this way
david um anton referred to the fact that
um moscow wanted quote a decisive
military victory on the ground do you
think that that is what we're leading up
to in the next few weeks or indeed
months i guess because there is a
prediction of course this could go on
for a very long time
yeah indeed i mean i i look i'm not a
military strategist and i certainly
don't pretend to to know what's going on
inside the head of president putin um i
i think the the explanation given is the
most plausible that they clearly
have not had the early military victory
that they hoped they had hoped i think
to take keeve install the puppet
government and basically declare victory
uh the ukrainian fierce resistance at a
huge cost but with great bravery has
stopped that and i think indeed they are
falling back perhaps to a military
outcome which can be described as a
victory that's that's what it looks like
but listen uh there could be many twists
and turns in this before
we see anything like a ceasefire or a
cessation of hostilities so i think we
need to be very very careful in in in
predictions because quite a few of them
have proven to be
misplaced in the early stages of this
conflict and even more recently so i
think it is the most plausible
explanation but uh i wouldn't say that
uh mr putin has completely given up on
the idea perhaps of
of a wider military victory or perhaps
linking uh
the eastern provinces with uh with
crimea through down through the south of
ukraine
there are probably a number of different
ideas circulating in in russian military
circles and it's a question of what they
think they can they can they can win at
and this is probably going to be tested
now in the next few weeks peter you were
nodding through that um do you get the
feeling that as far as negotiations are
concerned there's really not much point
in trying to
work out whether or not negotiations are
actually working until we get to the
point that our previous two guests have
talked about and russia has got what it
regards as a definitive military victory
indeed you know i would i would uh break
my answer into two components first of
all i would corroborate what the with
the
david has just said uh that you know
putin has not only not been dissuaded
from his uh idea to continue this war in
ukraine concentrate on the donbass i i'm
not even sure he's not been dissuaded
from trying to uh storm kiev a second
time uh you know uh
german uh chancellor uh schultz has
recently said that he is afraid that
robert putin's advisors are not giving
him the full picture of what is
happening in ukraine are not giving him
the precise figures of the number of
soldiers lost the ukrainians have
reported a number of almost 20 000
uh military dead we are not we're not
sure if mr putting deep in his bunker is
still
not receiving you know the true picture
of what's happening you know and the
second one uh is that you know uh once
again uh mr putin is hell-bent on
destroying ukraine as not just a
political entity but as a culture uh
there was a
a well you know a very widely quoted
piece published on the ria novosti ria
news which is a governmental website uh
a few days ago uh following butcher uh
which spelled out what russia's uh goals
should be in ukraine and basically the
the the gist of the article is that you
know it's clear that it's no longer this
some kind of anti-russian junta ruling
here but the entire you know ukrainian
people is very much uh against uh
russians against russia and so russia
needs to solve the ukrainian question by
trying to you know get rid of ukrainian
culture to
de-ukrainianize ukraine it's no longer
denotification of demilitarization it's
de-ukrainization folks so uh we take
that the theoretical we take the
practical butcher and we have all the
inklings of the genocide that is being
committed in ukraine
david they we mentioned right at the top
of the program that uh the president
zilenski has told al jazeera that russia
could renew its attack on kiev if
ukraine forces failed to hold russia on
the eastern front is there a concern do
you think in ukraine that foreign
governments may
frankly lose interest if the fighting
moves further east and towards the
russian government
i well i don't know what the people in
ukraine are thinking i would say seen
from
brussels with nato and the eu
uh i think that would not be the case i
mean i think people understand that this
is a hugely important conflict i mean
first and foremost because of the
enormous suffering of the ukrainian
people
the the the refugees the deaths the
destruction of property uh it's horrible
and none of us ever thought we would
live to see this in europe in our
lifetime and people have understood that
you know this is mr putin's war and this
is
you know nobody wants a direct
confrontation between nato and russia
for the obvious risks of nuclear that we
talked about
but i think people are not going to lose
interest in this or or or
feel anything other than the fact that
the outcome of this conflict is
absolutely fundamental for the future uh
security architecture of the european
continent
anton do you think that given the fact
that there's a lot of speculation this
conflict is going to
carry on it's going to be a long term
conflict afghanistan was a long conflict
that russian people had to go through do
you think that the russian people at the
moment are prepared to go through a
conflict that like that are they going
to tolerate something like that
yeah is a very good question i can
certainly say that russians do not quite
understand the scope of the conflict the
cost of the conflict i mean sanctions
only started to be manifested in the
country i mean they are expected to be
seen more in the summer and probably
even more so in the fall so this is
probably the horizon that we should be
looking at because up until the fall and
maybe the winter it would not be sort of
catastrophic for the russian economy and
it could be bearable for the propaganda
to manage the expectations of the people
uh if it takes longer than that it's
going to be highly problematic i mean
we're seeing kremlin react to any sort
of
sign of descent and home and is trying
to create a picture of total unity
behind the cause which is understood by
the majority of russians as russia's
fighting
uh nato in ukraine that's a proxy war to
defend russia i mean a lot of propaganda
there
being involved but i don't think it is
something that russia can endure for a
very long time so
it is critical to support and supply
ukraine for as long as possible so we
could stop russia's advance on the
ground militarily buying it more time
and the more time ukraine can resist the
less likely it would be for russia to be
able to maintain its pressure on ukraine
long term
anton
thank you very much indeed and i want to
say thanks to all our guests peter
zamayev david o'sullivan and anton
barber
and thank you to you too for watching
you can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me rob matheson and the
entire team here in doha goodbye for now